Diversity also is not just about religion,
ethnicity, gender and age. It's the definition.
The definition
we are talking about is how the person thinks.
Is the person analytical or critical thinker?
Is the person comfortable with technology?
So sometimes technological comfort is part of diversity.
If you are going to cascade a new project,
you have to understand which of the team members
are technologically savvy and which are not
and which one should be assigned which projects.
Okay? Third, communication style.
Is the person confrontational
or is the person passive aggressive?
It's the person passive aggressive.
It's the only time when you're meeting to him.
It's the email wagas,
comments
like this.
If you're talking to each other on zoom
or Microsoft Teams
let others use the chat box
if they're not comfortable with turning on their mic.
That's diversity.
Also in third is emotional maturity.
Some people can bring a constructive feedback.
I call it in our way, Sheila.
And some people are
professional enough to take on feedback.
How does the person receive it?
So diversity is acknowledging
my way is not the only way.
How can I adjust as a chameleon,
as a leader,
to be able to work with this person?
Okay? The ultimate goal is this.
If the people around you are walking on eggshells
just to talk to you,
you're a weak leader.
Okay? Because uma Asa kasa takot
don't for think.